we're going to begin this hour with big
news from meta formerly known as
facebook i still got to get used to that
not facebook it's meta giving parents
new tools to watch over teens who use
instagram and those vr headsets so
starting today parents will have more
power to supervise and limit their teens
time on both platforms and monitor
exactly what they're doing and who
they're interacting with so on the quest
vr headsets parents can now block apps
and require teens to get permission
before downloading or buying anything
adam assari he's the head of instagram
joins us only on cbs mornings to discuss
good morning to you adam it's so good to
see you again really good to have you
here thank you for having me
listen i know you've been working on
this stuff for a long time i know you're
a father i know that this is something
that's been very concerning to you so
what are you most what are you most
excited about as you make the changes
starting today
well we want to lead on teen safety
online and as a dad and as someone who's
talked to a lot of experts around the
world we believe that parents know
what's best for their children so what
i'm most excited about is providing more
tools for parents to shape their
children's experience on instagram and
on quest vr into what's best for their
teen for their child
so how do they do that adam exactly
because do the the parents have to get
permission from the teenagers or the
teenagers get permission from the
parents
how's that work exactly
you do have to establish that connection
and historically it had to be initiated
by the team but clearly that's not
sustainable so one of the changes that
we're launching this week is the parent
can actually initiate that relationship
and then they can see how much time
their team spends on instagram they can
set limits to that time one new feature
this week is that they can actually pick
periods of the week where their child
can't use instagram maybe it's homework
or school time and like you said similar
features on quest to shape their teen's
experience there as well
adam i appreciate these new tools as a
parent you know we are trying to find
new ways to not just peek into our
child's life but have an impact um but i
want to ask you about meta being sued we
know that meta is instagram's parent
company and they've been sued in eight
states with claims that facebook and
instagram are knowingly addictive to
young people for profit do you believe
that these new tools are
too little too late
i believe that one of our most important
responsibilities is keeping teens safe
online i believe this is an
industry-wide issue i think we're
leading on the issue i think we've
invested more than any other company and
safety more broadly these tools have
been in the works for a long time some
of them have launched years ago we're
actually raising awareness around
existing tools like take a break this
week i can't comment on any specific uh
ongoing uh of course
but um but i can say that i'm proud of
the work that we've done but i also
believe
and i'm committed to as a parent
that the work never ends and that we
have to continue to innovate in the
space
hey adam we all have a stake in this
because we're all parents here you've
got three young boys i'm not exactly
sure their ages but i would be curious
if you've begun to think about it as a
dad what is the age where you would say
to your kids all right instagram's right
for you
absolutely so my boys are six four and
two so they're too young um you have to
be 13 to use instagram but in general i
think this is an important question for
all parents not just about instagram but
about screen time we have our own rules
in our house where we do movie night
once a week and then on planes if we're
traveling then sort of all rules go out
the door um but for each child for each
parent it's different and so
again we want to make sure we empower
parents as much as possible
because they know better than we do
what's best for their children they know
better than anybody um and so you want
to lean into that as much as we can
i'm 100 with you on all rules go out the
window when you're traveling yes yeah
agree yeah that's right whatever it
takes we're right there with you special
occasion you get all the screen time you
want mom and dad are busy uh but i i
have a question on on leading on this
question yeah parents should have the
control they know what's best but you
could do a big assist to parents if you
police that age limit right so there's a
lot of 12 year olds even 11 year olds
are on there and all they do is lie
about their age i'm sure you guys have
the technology to know that there's some
there's some faking going on out there
any effort to
maybe police that age line a little bit
more closely
absolutely it's a difficult challenge
it's hard to verify the age of a 12 year
old versus a 13 year old when they don't
have ids for instance we do a lot on age
verification we removed over 2 million
people for being under 13 in the second
half of last year
alone we're always getting better at it
but we also want to be honest about the
fact that there is no proof way actually
we currently in this world ask every
single app to figure out their own
approach to age verification i actually
think it would be better for the phone
to verify age and then to provide that
age in a privacy safe way to each app i
think that could probably be safer for
the overall ecosystem
but for now we're committed to doing
everything we can to understand age
verify it and whenever we find someone
who is under 13 we remove them from the
account and we suspend their account
i think you said it best at the
beginning adam where you said parents
really do know best for their children i
grew up in a house where it wasn't a
democracy what my parents said went so
when i see all these options that kids
have i think that's also part of the
problems parents i think have got to
take control you've got a new feature
that says uh it's called nudge what is
that exactly
why do you think so we've all been
yeah we've all been in that place where
we've gone too deep on one topic online
i think we've all had that experience
where we popped up and wondered what
exactly happened so what nudge does is
if you spend a bunch of time on any one
topic it lets you know and then suggests
maybe you try something else we want to
make sure people feel good about the
time that they spend and instagram and
online more general more generally i
should say and so this is a way to
softly encourage that and right now it's
focused on teens and no matter what
topic you're going deep into if you go
particularly deep we let you know and we
suggest some other topics
all right adam asari we thank you it's
really good to see you thank you so much
thanks let's hope this makes a
difference
thanks for having me